I want to tell you a story about a
headline that implies something that
isn't quite true but it's still an
interesting story a bunch of articles
were written in the last 24 hours saying
high schoolers have recreated daraprim
that controversial Martin shkreli owned
drug for 20 bucks Australian high
schoolers made the drug for 20 bucks and
it sometimes sells for a hundred and ten
thousand dollars it's not exactly true
let me tell you what the real story is
there's this drug called daraprim which
is used to treat parasitic infections in
people with weak immune systems pregnant
women people with HIV etc the active
ingredient is called pyramid Amin you
might remember the controversy around
daraprim when in August of 2015
touring pharmaceuticals CEO Martin
shkreli bought the rights to the drug
and then brought the price up from 1350
per tablet $13.50 per tablet to seven
hundred and fifty dollars per tablet
huge fall out and we don't have to
rehash that entire story but that's the
drug that we're talking about since then
high schoolers from Sydney Grammer in a
sauce tray Leah have been working in
their school lab to create the drug
cheaply as the story goes in order to
draw attention to the inflated prices of
this drugs and they've succeeded for the
equivalent of 20 US dollars a group of
high school students created 3.7 grams
of the active ingredient used in the
medicine daraprim now to be clear we're
not talking about the drug itself we're
talking about the active ingredient you
would still need to further synthesize
that and put it into a delivery
mechanism is it a tablet is it a gel cap
what other ingredients are there but
still the active ingredient nearly 4
grams of it for 20 bucks
as far as touring is concerned following
the backlash the company did lower the
cost by about 50% but we're still
talking here about something that can
sell in the United States for tens of
thousands or even a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in most countries
including Australia daraprim is sold for
between one and two dollars per pill so
I think that this is a very interesting
story but to be clear they
didn't figure out how to do this that
there's there's a Wikipedia article and
many free resources which explain what
the formula is to synthesize this active
ingredient I don't think that's the
point the headlines were sort of
exaggerated but what is the point pad is
that the price is being charged in the
US are totally immoral price gouging
well wasn't it true that also Martin
shkreli bought the rights to this
particular drug so that no one else was
able to rival him and and compete yeah
oh yeah it was totally a play on being
the only provider and then bring the
price up and shrubs defense at the time
was this is not a drug that a lot of
people use so it's not like we bring up
the price and there might be millions of
people that can't afford this I think he
said there were only about two thousand
people on this drug and that they were
aware of every single one and that even
though they increased the book price
that they were ensuring that no
individuals were unable to get it and if
someone really couldn't afford it they
would give it to them for free that was
his explanation now whether that's true
or not I don't know but what it exposes
this what that explanation exposes that
supply and demand is totally skewed in
health care in the sense that if you're
really sick and you need a drug you
really need that drug and it skews the
entire concept of what a market rate is
and it completely disconnects it from
the costs of making that so here's an
example of sort of the lack of
transparency and this is a very common
situation imagine drug number one costs
$100 is the book price your copay with
insurance is ten bucks sounds pretty
good you just say hey it's ten bucks
that sounds great you have drug number
two it costs $300 at the book rate and
the copay is 25 so you say as a consumer
well I'm gonna go with the ten dollar
drug not the 25 dollar drug except the
manufacturer of the drug is offering a
coupon for patients to cover the twenty
five dollar copay so now patients say
well this drug is ten bucks this other
one is 25 but I've got a coupon for 25
so it's zero I go with the one that's
cheaper for me and it ends up with a
drug that's three times more expensive
being billed to insurance this is
exactly why you
end up with insurance costs going up
premiums going up it's just one aspect
of it just to illustrate one element of
it but this is why this is just
fundamentally not an industry that
should be thought of as an industry
where money is being made and it's why
the free market just shouldn't work in
in the context of health it's not like
you're coming out with a new style of
shoes or new high-tech television or
something this is something that's going
to impact people's health and well-being
and many countries have figured this out
many countries have figured this out
already so in any case headlines
overblown but an interesting story and
it illustrates real issues nonetheless
we will take a break and be back with
more after this remember you can join
the discussion with other viewers on our
reddit forum at david pakman.com slash
read it that's our EDD iti'm on there
every day I'll talk to you there Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s